we've avoided recession hurray
good morning I'm not sure I would join
in and saying hurray I think we've
technically avoided recession but the
truth is it's a very bad news story for
our country which does have huge
potential which the chancellor said and
I agree with him we do have huge
potential but I'm really worried looking
at the figures today we may have
technically avoided recession the
economy has been stagnant for the best
part of last year we are the only
country in the G7 that hasn't recovered
the economy to pre-covered levels and
have just seen statistics from the IMF
saying that we are projected to have the
lowest growth in the G7 countries this
year alone so we may have technically
avoided recession but my constituents
are feeling the pinch when it comes to
buying food going to food banks
realizing that they can't afford to feed
their children so I'm very worried
thank you
yeah I mean we have to be very cautious
when it comes to the IMF they don't
often get their predictions right is
what the government would say in
response to that but you are right
inflation is still very high ten and a
half percent in December for your
constituencies and others around the
country does it feel like a recession
I think it feels very difficult in terms
of the cost of living crisis so there's
a few things one is the price of food
the people I'm speaking to are talking
about how they can't afford the
essentials the basic food it's not
luxury food it's bread milk eggs things
are just spiraling out of control how
they have no choice but to go to food
banks the fact that the energy prices
are so high at the moment that they
can't afford to put their heating on and
people are very worried and this is what
we've asked for as a labor party we've
said that we shouldn't let Energy prices
get any higher in April and that's what
people are worried about are my energy
Bills going to go up even higher
the problem I think at the moment is
that there's no plan for growth from the
conservatives from the government
they've had 10 plans for growth since
2010 I looked at the figures they've had
four plans for growth in this Parliament
alone and yet it is it's achieved
nothing and that's what I'm worried
about and I'm worried that businesses
are losing the confidence in the
government as well the head of the CBI
came out and said that the government is
not doing enough that they don't have
enough ideas and Imagination to get at
get us out of this stagnant growth in
the economy so if we're losing the
confidence of businesses if yeah if
people in my constituents are feeling
that they can't afford to live their
lives then something's got to be done
and we need to see a proper plan for
growth from the chancellor and from the
government it's not good enough to say
we technically avoided recession that's
not good enough for my constituents and
it's not good enough for our country
um won the by-election uh last night
Ashley Dalton won West Lancashire I mean
that was a bit of a shoe-in wasn't it
it's been a labor seat for a long time
but I did look at the statistics and it
was a 10 swing to the labor party and an
11 swing away from the conservative so a
very good result you also have to bear
in mind that people have election
fatigue after having one election after
another is very cold voter turnout tends
not to be very strong when there's a
by-election and even that even then she
got 62 percent of the overall vote so
we're very proud of her I heard her on
the radio it sounds like the first thing
she's going to do when she gets into
Parliament is fight for the children's a
e so I think the government
um have to realize she's a force to be
reckoned with
just while I've got you miss Sadiq look
at these images of these people here in
Southeastern turkey adiraman 20 000
people being helped at this makeshift
Aid Center
um a thought from labor for them
the thought is that it's devastating to
watch
parents looking for their children under
the rubble I mean I don't know I can't
even imagine being in that situation but
we want to help in any way that we can
even if there's pressures on the current
Aid budget we want to make sure that we
help in every possible way we've also
got to remember that there were four
million syrians there who are already in
danger in the Northwest even before this
earthquake hit because of the conflict
we've got to make sure that we help them
as well some of the figures I saw talked
about there's a humanitarian Corridor
just one for the next six months and
we've got to increase access but what I
can say to you is that if we can help
with rescue operations with humanitarian
Aid with helping people get out of the
rubble we should be doing that as a
country the images are devastating and
my heart goes out to them